[Musique]
alors fait une fois nous départager
maintenant mais la dernière partie le
vent était contre nous là on a refait et
le perdant il fait à manger de tout
temps les hommes se sont crus au centre
de l'univers n'est certainement pas la
phrase par laquelle je commencerai déjà
parce que de tout temps les hommes c'est
de mauvais goût et ensuite parce que
c'est plutôt faut en fait il ya eu assez
tôt des philosophes pour soutenir que
nous occupons pas une place
particulièrement centrale ni même
significative dans l'univers nous des 5e
siècle avant jésus-christ les premiers
atomiste le cip et démocrite soutenait
que la terre n'est qu'un agrégat de
matière tombant dans le vide parmi bien
d'autres sans trop choquant dans un
grand jeu de pétanque cosmique et cette
idée sera reprise un peu plus tard par
epicure qui écrivait sans sourciller il
y à un nombre infini de monde semblable
au nôtre et un nombre infini de mondes
différents et toujours pour epicure il y
as entre ces mondes des dieux
bienheureux qui n'ont rien mais alors
vraiment rien à faire de nos petites
existences médiocre donc une yole au moc
et là je paraphrase un peu mais c'est
l'esprit ce type de cosmologie qui fait
de notre terre une place insignifiante
et dérisoire dans un univers aveugle et
chaotique cela semble coller assez bien
à l'idée que nous nous en faisons
aujourd'hui mais il est vrai que cette
conception rester très très très
marginale dans l'antiquité la cosmologie
dominante dans la pensée scientifique
grecque puis européenne avant l'époque
moderne c'est une cosmologie géo
centriste c'est à dire que la terre y
est conçu comme immobile au centre de
l'univers
et du coup unique forcément comme toutes
les grandes erreurs scientifiques on
attribue celle ci avant tout à aristote
qui en effet développé un système
géocentrique dont l' influence aura été
très importante même si en fait là
référence majeures en astronomie à
partir du 2ème siècle n'est pas le
système d'aristote directement mais le
système de tollé mais qui s'opposent à
ce dernier sur pas mal de points mais
qui adhèrent bien à cette conception géo
centriste alors était ce par stupidité
par mégalomanie ou par amour d'aristote
que les savants ont si longtemps soutenu
qu'ils étaient au centre de l'univers en
fait non on va voir pourquoi nous avons
eu pendant longtemps de très bonnes
raisons de le croire et ça permettra de
réfléchir de façon plus large à la façon
dont notre conception de la terre et du
reste de l'univers a évolué au fil de
l'histoire de la pensée scientifique
[Musique]
déjà halte aux préjugés sur les jets aux
centristes c'est pas parce qu'on pense
que la terre est immobile au centre de
l'univers qu'on pense aussi qu'elle est
plate
c'est même plutôt l'inversé le
géocentrisme et la terre sphérique ça se
marie parfaitement l'idée sous jacente
est en gros que les corps lourd sont
venus vers un même point central de
l'univers formant ainsi par accumulation
une sphère centré sur ce point et voilà
notre terre ronde immobile au centre de
l'univers tout ça est bien cohérent
par contre du côté de la team atomiste
de l'antiquité pour qui il y à une
infinité de mondes qui tombe dans le
vide
donc vraiment page et aux centristes
pour un sou eh bien eux ils soutenaient
que la terre est plate en forme de
cylindre aplati à parler donc plutôt que
de pétanque
j'aurais dû parler de curling cosmique
tout à l'heure alors vous me direz oui
mais bon tout le monde le pensait à
l'époque sahara sauf qu'en fait non
l'idée d'une terre ronde est assez vite
sur la table chez les grecs
elle s'impose à partir du 4e siècle
avant jésus-christ environ soit entre
démocrite et epicure en gros et quand
lucrèce poète latin épicurien du 1er
siècle avant jésus christ se moque des
défenseurs d'une terre ronde avec des
habitants aux antipodes qui seraient
attirés vers le centre de la terre au
lieu de tomber vers le bas évidemment
c'est en décalage complet avec la pensée
scientifique de son temps l'atomiste
épicurien c'est le plat tistes de
l'époque littéralement l'un des
principaux auteurs avoir fait pencher la
balance du côté de la terre ronde c'est
aristote dans son traité du ciel qui
donne une série d'arguments en faveur de
la sphéricité de la terre notamment des
arguments fondés sur des observations
astronomiques parce que oui la forme de
la terre peut se voir indirectement dans
le ciel notamment quand on observe
l'ombre de la terre lors d'une éclipse
de lune le contour de cette ombre est
parfaitement circulaires quelle que soit
la position de la lune au moment de
l'éclipsé or si la terre avait la forme
d'un palais de curling l'on n'aurait pas
toujours ce qu'on tour circulaire où on
verrait parfois la tranche de la terre
en quelque sorte le seul solide dont le
contour de l'ombre est parfaitement
circulaires quel que soit l'angle par
laquelle cette ombre est projeté c'est
la sphère et donc c'est cette forme là
seulement qui est cohérente avec ses
observations d'éclipsé pas le seul
argument ch aristote mais celui ci est
particulièrement élégant et solide et
ainsi cette conception d'une terre
sphérique immobile au centre de
l'univers
ou plus exactement dans le centre serait
le centre de l'univers
va devenir à partir du 4e siècle avant
jésus-christ la position la plus
largement acceptées en astronomie
voilà si tu vois cette fois ci tu fais
pas le con cours
je sais pas possémé été nul je vais
mettre de côté les questions qui
touchent à l'immobilité de la terre
parce qu'en fait c'est plus compliqué
qu'il n'y paraît je vais ici surtout me
pencher sur ce qui touche à la place de
la terre dans l'univers pourquoi nous
sommes-nous cru si longtemps au centre
ça n'avait rien de stupide naïf ou
narcissique il y avait entre autres un
argument astronomique de poids en faveur
de cette idée
un argument qui va revenir encore et
encore pendant 2000 ans au bas mot
l'argument de la parallaxe
mais qu'est ce que la parallaxe me direz
vous et bien pour l'expliquer je dois
d'abord développé ce que ça voudrait
dire d'être au centre de l'univers
l'univers c'est en somme tout ce qu'il y
avait notamment tout ce qui lie à au
dessus de nos têtes dans le vaste ciel
et quand on y plonge le regard par une
claire nuit d'été ce qu'il ya de plus
frappant est bêtement poétique ce sont
tous ces petits trucs briand qui
parsèment de toutes parts le ciel
nocturne
la voûte étoilée comme on dit tous ces
astres se déplace lentement au cours de
la nuit mais il occupe toujours la même
position relative les uns par rapport
aux autres ils se déplacent d'un seul
bloc en astronomie ancienne on parle
pour cette raison d'astres fixe et de la
sphère des fixes parce qu'à partir
d'aristote on a supposé que ces astres
étaient tous accrochés à une même sphère
en rotation autour de la terre ceci dit
l'argument astronomique dont je vais
parler ensuite fonctionne tout aussi
bien si on suppose que ces astres sont à
des distances différentes de la terre
donc de importe
vous me direz et les planètes alors on
en parle et je vous dirais mais oui elle
le mérite aussi les planètes en effet
différents ceux ci qu'elles ont des
positions variables dans le ciel par
rapport aux astres fixe c'est même ça
que ça veut dire à l'origine planétaire
en grec signifie errants ou vagabond les
planètes se sont les astres qui errent
qui se déplace
indépendamment des autres astres mais
bref les planètes la lune et le soleil
tout ça ça ne va pas intéresser ici
ce qui est important avant tout c'est
cette sphère des fixes les astronomes
ont rapidement compris que les astres
fixes sont plus éloignées que la lune le
soleil et ses quelques autres astres
vagabond à se faire des fixes constitue
en quelque sorte le faut l'arrière-plan
de l'univers et donc être au centre de
l'univers ce serait précisément être au
centre de cette sphère ultime le point
autour duquel tourne
toute la voûte étoilée mais donc
pourquoi avait-on de bonnes raisons de
penser ça et bien précisément parce que
ces astres fixe apparaissent fixe ça ne
convainc pas alors prenons un exemple
pour l'illustrer vous allez voir c'est
super simple on va prendre trois boules
qui vont faire trois astres fixe tiens
mes toiles à reste là très bien bien peu
plus près tu seras mieux la voilà très
bien ne bouge pas maintenant ça c'est le
soleil ça c'est la terre de ce point de
vue là qu'on regarde ces trois astres on
voit que l'ast revers est exactement au
milieu des deux astres rouge
mais si c'est la terre qui tourne autour
du soleil ça veut dire que six mois plus
tard la terre se retrouvent de l'autre
côté du soleil peu près ici à un
cochonnet près et ce qu'on voit c'est
que l'astre vert est maintenant plus
proche de l'astre rouge de gauche que de
celui de droite
non mais le but est de lancer les boules
c'est pareil expliqué des trucs avec
comme ça cette modification de la
position d'un astre en fonction de la
position de l'observateur c'est ce qu'on
appelle la parallaxe pour le dire le
plus simplement possible quand on bouge
les positions relatives des choses qu'on
observe douche aussi quand bien même
celle-ci ne bouge pas donc si
l'héliocentrisme est correct
l'héliocentrisme par opposition aux
géocentrisme c'est l'idée que c'est le
soleil qui est au centre et que la terre
et les autres planètes lui tout autour
ça impliquerait que la terre à six mois
d'intervalle passe d'un côté à l'autre
du soleil ce qui fait un sacré bout de
chemin et on s'attendrait dès lors a
observé un léger va et vient dans la
position des astres fixe ce qu'on
appelle une parallaxe annuel or c'est un
point sur lequel s'accordent toutes les
observations de tous les astronomes
galilée compris dans les observations
étaient bien plus précise grâce à
l'invention de sa lunette
on n'observe aucune parallaxe annuel
dans les astres fixe
coup dur pour les lieux centrisme
l'argument de l'absence de parallaxe on
le trouve déjà chez aristote et deux
mille ans plus tard lors du procès de
galilée
le cardinal bellarmin emploiera ce même
argument de la parallaxe pour justifier
que galilée n'avait pas de raisons
suffisantes de tenir les lieux centrisme
pour réel et ça a beau être aristote un
cardinal qu'ils disent contre galilée ça
n'en fait pas un mauvais argument c'est
un très bon argument
on a tendance à penser elle est
respectivement que la science était tout
entière du côté des élus centristes
copernic et galilée mais à vrai dire les
données de l'époque ne permettait pas de
trancher si clairement l'héliocentrisme
de copernic avait certes l'avantagé de
simplifier beaucoup la description du
mouvement des planètes qui dans les
systèmes géocentrisme devait être
décrits par un jeu complexe dépit cycle
c'est à dire
cercle tournant autour de cercle et
s'est senti le bricolage mais
l'héliocentrisme avait aussi ce gros
désavantage d'être bien difficiles à
réconcilier avec l'absence de parallaxe
annuel dans les astres fixe c'était un
sacré problème et vous allez voir que de
sa résolution des coûts les deux
conceptions radicalement opposées de
l'univers la première solution était de
n'accepter l'héliocentrisme que pour
déterminer le mouvement des planètes
tout en maintenant l'idée que la sphère
des fixes tourne autour de la terre
cela donne le modèle de tycho brahé où
la terre et fixes au centre de l'univers
la lune et le soleil tourne autour de la
terre et les planètes tournent autour du
soleil et non de la terre et la sphère
des fixes tourne autour de la terre
vous suivez on appelle ça un modèle géo
elio centriste et tout le monde est
content en somme on garde les
simplifications de calcul que permet le
système ait lieu centriste pour le
mouvement des planètes tout en laissant
la terre au centre pour ne pas bousculer
au delà de ça l'ordre du monde parce
qu'un faut pas pousser
vous n'en avez peut-être jamais entendu
parler mais tycho brahé grands
défenseurs de ce modèle c'est pas le
premier crétins venu c'est probablement
l'astronome le plus important de son
temps avec copernic son modèle geoeye
aux centristes a le mérite d'être simple
en tout cas plus simple que le modèle de
ptolémée et de coller très très bien au
mouvement apparent désastre tycho brahé
est un observateur excellent et il est
tout à fait prêt à admettre des
innovations théorie quand c'est
nécessaire par exemple quand il observe
l'apparition d'une nouvelle étoile en 15
172 ce qu'on appellera plus tard une
supernova ça va l'amener à rejeter de
vénérables idée aristotélicienne sur la
nature immuable des cieux et tycho brahé
connaît très bien le travail de copernic
qui l'admirent mais il rejette son
héliocentrisme est l'une des principales
raisons pour cela
en tout cas celle qui n'est le plus en
avant dans ses écrits scientifiques
c'est qu'il n'observe pas de parallaxe
dans la sphère des fixes c'est peut-être
un détail pour vous mais pour un
astronome du 16e siècle ça veut dire
beaucoup
ah oui épisode 5 collab valentine c'est
qu'il ya plein de légende autour de la
mort de tycho brahe maintenant tu sais
en fait on sait qu'il est mort en 1601 à
l'âge de 54 ans à prague
par contre on sait pas de quoi il est
mort arias plein de théorie un peu
obscur des trucs à limite compléter sur
les bords pendant longtemps la thèse qui
a été privilégiée c'était celle
l'empoisonnement au mercure parce que
son assistant kepler aurait voulu
profiter du laboratoire en entier donc
du coup il aurait voulu le liquider
1 il ya une autre théorie que je trouve
particulièrement croustillante qui dit
que en fait ça aurait était le cousin de
tycho brahé qu'on a voulu tuer sur indre
du roi de l'époque l'europe danemark
parce que en fait tycho brahé aura un
peu fait des choses pas très catholiques
avec le père et la mère et roux la mère
du roi et du coup il a été exhumé deux
fois un dico c'est plus que beaucoup de
gens et du coup il ya des chercheurs qui
ont été analysés plein de chausse ses
vêtements ses cheveux ça me va et ils
ont trouvé des taux de mercure
passablement voilà mais pas non plus
mortelle donc a priori cette thèse est
écartée évoque la thèse privilégiée par
les enquêteurs
c'est au contraire l'insuffisance rénale
parce que alors son assistant kepler
raconte donc c'est une source de
première main que tiko ce serait retenue
de faire pipi lors d'un banquet où il
était invité parce qu'elle voulait pas
enfreindre l'étiquette forcément se
levant de table en plein milieu des
agapes et du coup une fois rentré chez
lui il arrivait plus à faire pipi et il
ya une longue agonie comme ça de 11
jours et il est mort après ça de cette
retenue de faire pipi ou peut-être c'est
tragique mais montera duc et du coup la
légende raconte que encore eu que
pendant ces 11 jours là il aurait écrit
sa propre épitaphe qui est il a vécu
comme un sage et il est mort comme un
con bon on joue maintenant
les élus centristes ne se laissait pas
démonter et ils pouvaient répondre à
l'argument de la parallaxe bien sûr le
problème c'est que la seule réponse
possible était assez coûteuse disons
l'héliocentrisme implique qu'il doit y
avoir une parallaxe annuel des astres
fixe il ne le conteste pas or on
n'observe pas de parallaxe ça non plus
il ne le conteste pas et donc cette
absence d'observation ne peut
s'expliquer que 6,7 parallaxe est trop
petit pour être observable aussi bien à
l'oeil nu pour moyen de la lunette de
galilée ou plus tarder premier télescope
or qu'est-ce qui fait que la parallaxe
est plus ou moins grande et donc plus ou
moins détectables c'est d'une part la
distance qui sépare les deux poids entre
lesquels l'observateur se déplacent mais
aussi la distance entre les astres
observés et les points d'observation
mais cette fois-ci thibault tu gères
j'ai une idée tenez vos boules regardez
là du point de vue de la terre on a un
alignement des astres qui est similaire
à celui de tout à l'heure sauf que vous
êtes quelques mètres plus loin
et donc quand au bout de six mois la
terre se retrouvent de l'autre côté du
soleil à nouveau vous voyez que l'astre
vert s'est décalé vers l'astre rouge de
gauche mais beaucoup moins au nom mais
il me saoule avec ces planètes là allez
viens valentine on se casse si vous vous
éloignez suffisamment ça deviendra quasi
imperceptible même avec des instruments
très sensible la réponse des élus
centristes sera donc toujours là même si
la parallaxe est indétectable c'est
parce que les astres fixes sont très
très très très éloignées mais la
distance minimale nécessaire semblait
vraiment énorme cela impliquait en gros
que la distance entre la terre et le
soleil devait être dé l'histoire par
rapport à la distance entre la terre et
les plus proches des astres fixe
moyennant cette supposition selon
laquelle les astres fixons
extraordinairement éloigner le système
de copernic et le système de tycho brahé
font exactement les mêmes prédictions
astronomiques et ne peuvent être
distingués par là mais cette supposition
d'une sphère des fixes
extraordinairement éloigné n'est pas
anodine l'héliocentrisme n'implique pas
seulement que la terre n'est pas au
centre de l'univers cela implique aussi
que les dimensions de l'univers sont
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus grande
que celle du système solaire avec la
terre et les planètes et contre celui ci
et le reste des étoiles c'est un espace
vide démesurée
[Musique]
alors bien sûr cette idée d'une distance
énorme entre le système solaire et les
étoiles nous est familière aujourd'hui
même s'il est difficile de prendre
vraiment la mesure de ce que ça signifie
mais une telle conception était beaucoup
plus difficile à admettre pour un esprit
du xviie siècle où avant cela jusque là
l'univers ne paraissait pas devoir être
inconcevablement immense et
principalement vide dans le système de
tollé mais on évaluer la distance
terre-soleil à 1210 fois le rayon de la
terre ce qui est déjà assez en dessous
de la réalité vu que c'est plutôt 23
mille fois hélas distance de la terre à
la sphère des fixes rester dans un ordre
de grandeur similaire le fait même d'en
parler comme d'une sphère comme d'une
voûte étoilée
ces caractéristiques d'une conception
d'un monde clos renfermé au sein de
cette voûte ce petit problème de
parallaxe avait donc des conséquences
assez vertigineuse sur la conception
qu'on se fait de l'univers ou bien c'est
un monde clos dont les dimensions
restent raisonnables de l'ordre de
quelques dizaines de milliers de fois le
rayon de la terre et la terre n'occupe
le centre ou bien la terre n'est pas au
centre
elle tourne autour du soleil et cela
implique que l'univers est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus vaste et
peut être infinie qu'un espace vide
absurdement gigantesque nous sépare des
plus proches des toiles et que celle ci
pour rester visible de si loin doivent
être décoré normes de la dimension de
notre soleil au moins autrement dit que
ce sont d'autres soleils très éloignées
et ce point d'ailleurs temps à réfuter
l'héliocentrisme compris comme la thèse
selon laquelle notre soleil serait au
centre de l'univers
si les lieux centrisme a pour
conséquence qu'il doit y avoir d'autres
soleils très éloignées pourquoi accorder
aux nôtres ce statut spécial
tout ça semble plutôt finalement penché
en faveur de l'idée qu'il n'ya pas du
tout de centre de l'univers regardant le
ciel nous ne nous sentirions plus sous
une voûte
mais comme le disent et admirablement
pascal dans une sphère infini dans le
centre est partout et la circonférence
nulle part tout ça à cause d'une foutu
parallaxe qu'on ne peut pas observer
finalement l'épreuve se sont accumulés
en faveur du mouvement de la terre en
particulier à partir du moment où la
théorie de la gravitation de newton a
permis de donner une justification
physique à ce mouvement la terre tombe
sur le soleil comme le boulet de canon
tombe sur la terre la mécanique
terrestre obéit à la même loi
universelle de gravitation que la
mécanique céleste
il faut bien l'admettre elle tourne et
nous sommes ainsi passés du monde clos
des anciens à l'univers infini des
modèles la première estimation précise
de la distance d'une étoile
on la doit à l'astronome allemand
friedrich wilhelm bessel en 1838 grâce à
la méthode de la parallaxe justement la
précision des télescopes s'étant
suffisamment améliorée pour permettre de
détecter la parallaxe annuel des étoiles
les plus proches un si beau seul estime
la distance de l'étoile cini 61 à
environ 10 points 5 années-lumière ce
qui était assez correct la véritable
valeur étant un peu supérieure à 11
le plus proche voisine parmi les étoiles
sont à une distance de cet ordre de
grandeur quelques années lumière et on
pourrait déjà se poser la question à
quel point c'est au delà de l'idée qu'on
se faisait de la sphère des fixes dans
l'antiquité
difficile d'avoir des distances précise
mais sachant que chez ptolémée la
distance terre-soleil est de 1210 fois
le rayon de la terre et en admettant que
la distance à la sphère des fixes n'est
pas 100 fois supérieure à cela
l'ordre de grandeur de la sphère des
fixes ne dépasserait pas 100 ou 200
mille fois le rayon de la terre traduit
en kilomètres ça donne quelque chose de
l'ordre du milliard de kilomètres les
étoiles les plus proches sont à
plusieurs années lumière et une année
lumière c'est presque dix mille
milliards de kilomètres ainsi nos plus
proches voisines dans l'univers sont
déjà éloigné de nous d'une distance qui
est supérieur d'un facteur dix mille ou
cent mille à l'idée que l'on se faisait
dans l'antiquité de la distance des
astres les plus éloignés ouais il a bien
grossi l'univers et ce n'est qu'un début
dans les années 1920 les astronomes
commencent à comprendre que la nébuleuse
d'andromède est en fait une autre
galaxie constitué de centaines de
milliards des toiles et on parvient à
estimer son éloignement au moyen de
différentes méthodes qui s'accordent sur
une valeur proprement vertigineuse
environ 2,5 millions d'années lumière
c'est difficile de prendre la mesure de
ce cartel éloignement veut dire une
année lumière c'est presque dix mille
milliards de kilomètres et s'est déjà
incroyablement démesuré pour nous que
veut dire cette distance multiplier 2,5
millions de fois entre nous et la
galaxie d'andromède et ce n'est que
notre plus proche voisine
on observera plus tard encore des
galaxies éloignées 2000
art d'années lumière à nouveau c'est un
saut d'ordre de grandeur et ce sceau des
étoiles au galaxy et même beaucoup plus
important que le précédent
l'idée que l'on se faisait de la taille
de l'univers avait été multiplié par dix
mille ou cent milles environ en passant
de la sphère des fils des anciens aux
étoiles éloigné des modernes mais en
passant ensuite des étoiles au galaxy un
astronome du début du xxème siècle aura
vu dans sa carrière la taille de
l'univers plus exactement l'éloignement
des objets les plus lointains qu'il peut
observer multiplié par un facteur de
l'ordre du milliard tout ça au cours
juste de quelques décennies de recherche
c'est un vertige tellement inconcevable
qu'il semble être passée presque
inaperçue
je remplace arnaud et pour ton histoire
d'univers on est quand même au centre de
l'univers observable
oui on peut dire ça mais bon l'univers
observable c'est pas l'univers tout
court
quoi le numéro la vitesse de la lumière
elle est finie donc plus tu va regarder
quelque chose de loin plus tu va
regarder quelque chose qui est loin dans
le temps tu va remonter le temps et
comme battus 7 l'univers il est en
expansion
et bien quand tu remonte dans le passé
l'univers tu arrive à un point où il est
très concentré il ya après 13,8
milliards d'années et ultra dense et et
a donc ce qu'on appelle le big bang
première lumière de l'univers et au delà
tu peux pas le temps mais finalement et
donc l'ensemble de notre univers
observable
ça représente une bulle de 13,8
milliards d'années et nous on est pile
poil au centre au delà de ça on n'a
aucune raison de penser que l'univers ne
continue pas de s'étendre et même la
question de savoir si l'univers est
infini où finit en physique aujourd'hui
c'est pas tranché prophète et du coup là
je me sens tout effrayé par silence
éternel de ces espaces infinis et je
vois vraiment pas comment je pourrais
continuer à jouer à la pétanque
on sait faire merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à discuter en commentaire sur le
discorde du vortex est ce que vous
trouvez que l'univers est beaucoup trop
grand vous avez quatre heures
[Musique]
finalement qu'on ait gagné ou perdu ça
change pas grand chose
peut-être mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il a
réagi comme ça enfin je veux dire ça se
fait pas mais tout le monde sait qu'il
est mieux de la pétanque pourquoi tu
l'as pris dans ton équipe
pourquoi je les prie de monique parce
qu'il m'a dit j'ai jamais perdu à la
pétanque
bah c'est sûrement vrai parce
qu'aujourd'hui il a été très nul et il
n'a pas perdu au le fumier
[Musique]